but anything if prom night in American
Pie resulted in pregnancy which we know
it didn't but if it did and the crew
from American Pie could have kids that
are old enough now to go to prom that's
the kids from American Pie would be old
enough to be the parents and blockers
Matt's making you feel old - I know
[Music]
blockers is called blockers
the title is blockers but it has that in
front of it which is a clever way
of getting around the head so
blockers is essentially the hole we want
to lose our virginity at prom story high
school teen sex comedy we've seen it a
hundred times before in blockers
it's a group of three friends that want
to lose their virginity on prom night
and the parents get wind of this they
start freaking out so they wanna you
know block them now we have a movie
of a night of shenanigan and I want to
give props to the cast in this movie
they're three friends it was I didn't
even think about how they worked
together so well chemistry and movies is
a funny thing when it sucks it's obvious
when it works really well you almost
don't notice it because it's so
organically flows kinda like you notice
you don't usually notice the visual
effects in a movie unless they saw
visual effects you're used all the time
and when they're good you don't notice
that they're even being used some people
now are like CGI stop bad CGI sucks and
it's noticeable that's how chemistry is
and that's how it is with this crew this
crew so organically feels like best
friends I wouldn't be surprised if
they're actually best friends in real
life unlikely I'm saying they were all
really great they didn't overdo it there
weren't cartoon versions of themselves
you just felt like three girls are
hanging out in high school maybe you
want to get some ass tonight who knows
that's for the parents the standout was
this dude this dude you've seen a lot of
things including the best movie of all
time Suicide Squad owning it at this
point
this dude's this show stealer he's the
one I remember in this movie because
he's that character that just sticks
with you in a comedy at least a comedy
based around family as always that
friend who's kind of a burnout doesn't
have his together but damn it he's
the funniest one to watch on screen but
he's also the one you don't want as a
facebook friend Leslie Mann's really
good we've seen her in comedies but I
know her from so you know she has it
Johnson there's the one I want to talk
about because very rarely does someone
who's known for you know physique oh you
know what I want to do acting and I'm
gonna go straight to comedy usually they
blow up and then end up being
comedies later down the road he's like
out the gate I want to do comedy and
generally he does good in the movie what
I love most about this movie is how they
deal with it how they address it it
being sect the movies very self-aware it
comes from a very current angle you know
comedies like this thus far we have the
parents are like my kids aren't getting
sex tonight that's a parent that's like
the dad from 10 Things I Hate About You
as how parents are supposed to react
right and some do act this way is it
normal
not a knee-jerk reaction sure but
follow-through that that's where
insanity comes in it's kind of nuts this
movie deals with that it addresses that
I also like the fact that it's set apart
from other comedies like this in the
sense that most comedies that have this
premise are like well sex is the end
game that that's what we're going for
that is the goal sex for the sake of sex
this movie treats it a little
differently like sex is an action but
that's not what else is there movie
feels more layered than most those
movies with this premise anyway and this
movie had me laughing I was never in
tears or definitely movies I have
laughed harder in lately probably not a
girls trip that one was pretty
hysterical but this movie definitely did
have the laughs bummer is so did the
trailer a couple of the big left's you
can tell they were like all right this
is our ace in the hole gonna save this
for the movie but we're also gonna show
it in the trailer when it was coming it
was building and I knew what was coming
sure enough it happened I was like guys
on the trailer you don't want to spoil
the funniest moments in the trailer but
comedies usually do that there's tough
line to walk for comedies you got to
sell the movie in the trailer you do
that by showing funny stuff how much is
too much the trailer for this movie did
I think across the line of it and some
of the editing was choppy in parts one
scene in particular not gonna spoil it
for you but it does have to do with
lights being out it's very dark and I
was like there is no way anyone can get
out of this scenario very next scene
they're rolling down the street like oh
man that was crazy like how did you get
out of that I guess we'll never know
maybe the cutting room floor has
something will show in the blu-ray but
in the end with blockers I had a good
time it's not just that it was a pretty
funny movie by the end of this movie I
was like this movie had a lot of heart
that's where I feel the payoff is if a
scene supposed to make you laugh maybe
it doesn't lessor sentimentality as a
backup the first act is a bit choppy as
it tries to get going but once it does
get going it is a good time no
alcoholics wire what anything is when I
reflect on the demographic this movies
meant for it's obviously geared for
teenagers and their parents but I feel
like it does aim towards the parents
more just keep that in mind alright so
blockers which is actually called
blockers but they can't say
blockers on the poster so we do have an
icon have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]